[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're just joining us rudy giuliani
is sweating his face off explaining to
us why trump really won the election
again inspectors
every state
almost every approved this
was thrown away
gone for eternity is this a skit the
only thing left is to have been a dead
person
that could have been not filled out
probably wait he's saying there was a
dead person in the envelope
rudy's about to have actual drops of
sweat coming off of his brow i mean is
this a normal amount i don't know how
hot it is in the room but this something
seems very wrong here all be in the
lawsuit that comes out duty's melting
arizona is a ca as a state that we're
looking at very very carefully strongly
looking at it i would say we're probably
i assume she's working if she's working
for them
i'd like to read them all to you but i
don't have the time
you should have had the time managed to
go look for that
[Music]
that's your job
like it's my job to defend the president
and represent the president
michigan wisconsin is is he bleeding did
you see is he bleeding from his ear
what on earth was that needed
to find out
does that hair dye is to look at the
lawsuits in order to do it it looks like
blood
been in the material oh my god it's
everywhere ten
thousand at least
and we're getting he's gotta get off the
stage and there are other aspects of
this fraud on the morning of november
someone's got to get him a napkin they
were going to count the these this new
kind of battle
i've never seen anything like this
what on earth it's getting onto his
shirt now she can and it was con any
jury would accept as they heard this
evidence
that somebody had this plan this is
insane maybe that was always the plan
it looks like sapped from an oak tree or
a maple tree it looks like someone's
making syrup
the city described that to you oh my god
it's all over his face
he's gonna need a towel dealing with it
i don't know guys it's sounding like
trump won isn't it based on this
[Music]
moment of the sexual experience would
ask the young lady who's your daddy this
should be remixed if officer akeemov is
watching this could be the next remix
masterpiece dude because just wait till
you see what happens here oh officer
officer akimov is here uh that's
beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
i'm joined today by pastor james david
manning
[Music]
a long-legged mack daddy is the most
successful pimp on planet earth to
reverence the word of god to trust it to
preach it to teach it
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lies
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
george bush singer and george bush jr
have been penetrated by at least 100 men
in their anus 100
200 000 strong i didn't do it that's not
my problem oh i got down on my knees
i didn't do it i was tempted
sounds like quite an
[Music]
loads of evening
and tons and tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
[Music]
and loads of money and tons and tons of
lives
let me say something to you about
marketing
[Music]
starbucks has done the exact same thing
that coca-cola has done except they've
done it we've seen it
that certainly seems to be a story that
has been missed
[Music]
all right welcome everybody it is an
old-fashioned press briefing live stream
on all platforms it's great to be here
i am i was uh not i from the standpoint
of live streams i was a bit absent last
week although we did do the trump uh
rally i was building out the bunker
studio and we've made a bunch of
technical upgrades there as well as here
um here i am happy to tell you i have
now expanded from the regular stream
deck to the stream deck xl i brought the
little one to the bunker studio this is
going to give me uh oh
almost lost my gavel we'll get to that
um this is going to give me a lot more
variety without having to go through
multiple pages from the standpoint of
audio and we'll look at some of those
clips that i've added to the stream deck
momentarily i also now as a permanent
setup on the the studio i have an
additional microphone now you might be
looking at this and saying sir i'm not
hearing you through that and that's
absolutely right this is for when we
take discord calls so that instead of
sounding so far away
people on discord will hear me better i
don't think it's going to improve the
quality of the calls at all
uh the problem with the call quality is
a different one but we have an
additional microphone just off camera
here so that people via discord calls
can better hear me
and that's a really good thing i've got
my new fall sweater
um it's fantastic i also have a mustache
just as a joke i kind of i decided to do
like a pervert mustache um
my girlfriend doesn't like it i might be
allowed to keep it one more day
but uh i don't know it's just it's kind
of a goof
it's a total goof
um but we've got that so that's what's
going on and you're probably wondering
where these six came from it's from
people who already signed up and in fact
we're actually at eight already this is
it's an incredible day um thanks to aj
skorpia and neptune jay tandaway this is
blood deeper shades of house
polo dal
masik and gordon z hall
for already
signing up via
twitch and i appreciate that our coupon
code
felony21 is up and running on the
website it's all happening and i have so
many things for you i have jimmy from
philly voicemails i have unbanned
requests let's first just go through
some new material i now have my bernie
jlp and biden clips all on one page
of the
um stream deck so now i can easily go
from for example
i can go from that directly into
and straight into
and by the way maybe you could inject
some bleach in your arm and that would
take care of it with all due respect
that's a bunch of malarkey get
vaccinated yeah okay so i've got all of
those on one page now which is great
i have a songs area which still needs to
be built out we've got
you never know when you'll need it
okay i've got this
and then they did dumps they call them
dumps big massive dumps
uh in michigan and pennsylvania
okay you guys get that and then uh we i
definitely need more songs but then i've
got this one too then they did dumps
they call them dumps big massive dumps
michigan and pennsylvania
[Music]
oh my god i can't turn it off there we
go so we've got that
um and then i've got a couple new well
hold on a second what's going on then
i've got a couple new um
trump clips
let me see what are my new uh so i've
got a couple new trump clips these
aren't people these are animals
right
um
elements of bathrooms
what else do i have that's new because
you'd be in jail
um
take a look at the oranges of the
investigation
i know i have other new ones
one of the wettest we've ever seen from
the standpoint of water
they are doing studies on donald trump
that's new that's a new one
you are a rude terrible person that's
new i don't throw babies out believe me
yep you know it's called science
we need money
you know we have a world right
we do we we have a world um and then
i've got you know all of my other
classics as well those those don't go
away i don't even know what i'm doing
sir
sir your wife is up in the air
sir sure yeah all right so anyway here's
my request if if small fuzzy moss or
others are in the chat
what would be great to add to the sound
board is
audio of when callers criticize me like
when eric from mass calls it and goes
well david you've did it you did it
again or jimmy from philly i think that
would be good just a compilation of
callers criticizing me and then the one
other idea i had which would be cool for
a pre-stream intro would be
um there was this image floating around
of
me giving myself a medal and it's from
the obama giving someone the
presidential medal of freedom and it was
like me giving myself a medal for the
bonus show because we joke about the
award-winning bonus show but it's awards
we've given if someone could actually
make a deep fake video of that i know
that the still image is orders of
magnitude simpler than doing a full deep
fake video but if someone could do that
that would make the day we debut that
would be an historic day
okay so that's an idea
as far as that goes
um and then also lastly thank you to um
oh hold on a second thanks to endy's
billy carpenter dirt knapp and ajador
for the twitch prime subscriptions
very much appreciate that okay
do you guys want to go next to jimmy
from philly voicemails
uh oh i would say super chats but
there's no super chats or unban requests
which would people will do both but i
just don't know what people would prefer
first
we could really do either
um
the jimmy voicemails okay i haven't
pre-screened these now remember
jimmy's been calling and it's just
playing noises in the background so
let's let's see what we've got okay here
we go
so that's nothing it's just blank
i guess we don't really have anything
oh here's one
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay so jimmy really having all sorts of
problems with this phone here's one more
this one's just blank
and one last one
this one's blank as well
okay so that's the jimmy voicemails
clearly experiencing some kind of
technical difficulties
problems with technology
um yep all right that's it as far as
jimmy goes okay let's get to the unban
requests i guess
um here we go when you get banned on
twitch you can appeal that you can send
a message requesting to be unbanned and
i will adjudicate these here
um here's a user
named a troll account it's already not
looking good
they um
showed up and said trump 2024. that's
okay that's allowed
then they said trump makes money biden
loses memory
okay they were banned
and their unban request is why are you
silencing my political voice [ __ ] so
that's a deny
and permaban
very very easy one
let's go next to
um a user named d
at t
who said um
they were apparently bullying someone
then they said needle junkies and then
their unban request is why did you ban
me this wasn't me this one it seems like
there was a problem at the moment but
this is seeming not
that crazy i'm gonna unban this person
and see how they behave
all right
and then lastly
here is a user named living martyr
report
they were banned
they were banned a year ago oh this is
interesting this is someone who was
banned a year ago and they've they came
across the channel again and didn't
remember why they were banned this is so
funny so
living martyr report was banned on
halloween of 2020
and they said um
what were they banned for
they said you have the same chance of
dying in a car accident than dying from
covid
under the age of 70. wake up stop using
china as a political tool it's so
obvious and disgusting okay so they seem
to be minimizing covet i guess they were
banned a year ago then they then showed
up and said
it's interesting i'm here because of
dylan burns yet you banned me because
you didn't like the fact that i
corrected you on a subject but i
unironically i am a fan of dylan burns
why because he is a progressive that
respects difference of opinions
especially when he can admit he is wrong
i don't want to be unbanned i would
rather you know that there are a few
people on twitch that are intelligent
and for them me to be banned because you
are afraid to admit you're wrong says
everything good luck yeah um i'm gonna
unban them i know they're not saying
they wanna be um unbanned but they were
banned a year ago for something they did
so maybe they've uh smartened up okay
so welcome back you're unbanned
and
i guess that's it as far as the unbanned
requests go
jeffrey moore is asking via super chat
although you can't yet see them because
the first couple you can't see
david sir what's your favorite guilty
pleasure food i don't really think about
foods in that way
it's just i try to eat a balanced diet
so i don't know about guilty pleasure
um yeah i just it's just not the way i
approach nutrition i apologize jeffrey
also michelle says please ban the brian
laundry troll on youtube yeah moderators
i spotted that as well please keep an
eye out oh hold on i see them
um
bam there we go
boom very strong ban
yeah they were just taking over
everything it was super annoying super
annoying
i want to say thank you to senor safe
for subscribing via twitch prime you
were number 13
very much appreciate that
okay
let's get to a couple of other things
now as we are standing by for jen saki
oh oh oh oh hold on let me make an
announcement
very big announcement
we are announcing
a viewer town hall
where i will just be opening the discord
lines and hearing from people we're
going to open it up people who have been
trying to get on and haven't been able
to we're going to be doing it this is
going to be make a note of this folks
i'm about to give you a date
the date is
tuesday october 19
at 6 p east
3p west
however here's the catch
this
live viewer town hall open to everyone
is only going to be streaming
on the new
pacman live youtube channel okay it will
only be here
this is the one place where it will
stream so if you're going to be hanging
around on the main channel looking for
this stream you won't see it
if you're going to be looking on tv
you're not going to see it there this is
an exclusive live because it's pacman
live we're going to be live okay
tuesday october 19
6 p east 9 3p west
with priority on callers to website
members okay so if you've been thinking
of getting a website membership
you might as well do it now because
we're the members are going to be just
you're going to be able to get right on
it's going to be an incredible day
this is a pacman live exclusive
and that's going to be tuesday october
19th so please please please
uh get signed up over there i think it's
going to be fantastic it's going to be
absolutely fantastic all right we expect
this stream to get some awards uh pat is
coming up with the list of awards now
but
uh that's going to be on tuesday
october 19th
and we're doing it early enough that
hopefully fewer people will be drunk all
right major major announcement major
major announcement
speaking of announcements no not
announcements but speaking of other
things
check this out
um herschel walker
is a republican running for
senate
in
where georgia maybe where does anybody
know where herschel walker is running i
think it's georgia
yeah
herschel walker's son
is a
conservative
and now he was on fox news yesterday
to push back against cancel culture
and it's a complete and total cringe
stream this this is just crazy this is
herschel walker's son christian walker
who's a conservative commentator
i don't know guys take a look you've got
every once in a while bill maher say
truth matt tybee what's your take
christian walker weighing in on the
culture wars click on all of this
maria i think it's the left's
aggressiveness that's begun to shake
people awake to their lives we have the
cancel culture we have lies like the
russia gate lie the big russia gate lie
we have the big russia gate line
the terrorist attacks also known as the
blm rights that overtook our country for
months on end that the left encouraged
people have had enough of this but a lot
of everyday americans are scared to
voice their dissent because of the
violent tactics the left uses against
people what is he talking about like
what on earth is this guy talking about
we see celebrities start to take up the
front lines and use their public
platforms to voice their descent we're
gonna see a domino effect and we'll see
every american start to do the same
which is super exciting
well it's incredible luigi yeah it's all
incredible but this is the latest
um
is he now it says celebrities push back
against cancel culture is this guy the
celebrity or is this guy commenting on
celebrities pushing back against
canceled culture i don't really know
but uh nobody knows what that segment
was about very strange segment
here's another interesting one
fox news ran an article which says
democrat tammy duckworth hasn't paid
property tax on her illinois home since
2015. oh my god
it's another take take take democrat
unwilling to pay taxes themselves they
want other people to oh wait a second
hold on
50 disabled veterans don't need to pay
property taxes on their primary home
oh wait a second tammy duckworth lost
both her legs
serving the country and is 70 disabled
oops
oh no here's another democrat not paying
taxes give me a break guys give me a
break supposedly they they support the
troops
and of course an alter i even tweeted an
alternative headline another way to say
this would be
veteran who lost both her legs is
legally paying no property tax as
allowed for 50 plus percent disabled
veterans
these people are disgusting
they do not deal in facts it's just
absolutely pathetic
um so that's the latest fox news
headline
uh really really wacky stuff
all right we're standing by for it's
it's it's vile it's vile
thanks to cactus matt as well as diom's
dirty curta
for signing up via twitch you are
numbers 14 15 and 16 today
we do have this coupon code felony 21
available today you can use that code to
get a discounted membership at
joinedpakman.com i would do it right now
because in two weeks we're doing a live
viewer town hall
and members will get priority okay it's
sort of like when you go to a club
and you've got this big line all around
and everybody's trying to figure out oh
how can i get up there is the bouncer
going to let me in
members are like those [ __ ] who get
right out of a car
and they go right to the front of the
line and are let in
okay now i don't know that that's
necessarily something to be bragging
about but it's just what it is so i'm
just telling you we're going to be doing
this uh incredible event two weeks from
now be one of them they're vip exactly
all right good uh we have another brian
laundry troll we're gonna ban them
they got banned here's king basher who
says via super chat please ban brian
laundry he keeps spamming yep we've done
it
brian laundry is banned
all taken care of
uh they may come back with another uh
with another username all right let's
get to a few
voicemails we now have the voicemails
are essentially unusable now we've got
like 600 unread on listen to voicemails
i do want to say thanks to pen rabbit
and chief boris for the twitch prime
subscriptions your number 17 and 18.
um let's get right into
some of these callers here is one of our
new frequent callers
and and david i'll show you talk to
jesse you can ask him about ptsd i'm
sure he knows all about it
it's it's a it's a defect in the
circuitry in your brain that deals with
time
okay called right back and i'll further
david and say that mediums are real
not all of them obviously just like
there's fakes of everything but yep i
don't believe that psychic mediums are
real i think they're
[Music]
hey there scams again and just so you
understand i'm not a religious person i
[ __ ] hated religion since i took it
all right then every single one of these
voicemails is a full three minutes
and dave did you ever get that feeling
that that
sudden chill that deep deep-seated bone
chill that you just can't explain
a bone chill i've never had a bone chill
and i would type in email david but my
fingers are i have some real [ __ ] up
fingers from accident so my typing
skills have uh i'm sorry to hear that
here you read it slightly oh
i just hope you don't take me as a wacko
i know how well it sounds okay yes it
does sound strange
[Music]
this is jacoby genovese another one of
troy york's fake characters i just
wanted to know that blacks for trump's
does exist i know several
black people who are involved with trump
campaign
and who support him
there are many blacks in fact um i also
wanted all right troy york says blacks
for trump are real
uh best lemon from bandy fair is a far
left marxist
undemocratic socialist or anything she
writes about mac dates should be
did he say mac mac dates i think they
were mandates not mac dates the vaccine
a vaccine mac date that's something
and uh i just want to know uh
what kind of sick twisted
uh
tactic is what you use you just
mentioned a bunch of clients that have
nothing to do with matt gates
oh god i'm so bored with him all right
then we're going to our friend whitney
so um what do you think as far as
marijuana goes is
for the progressive party moving forward
um
because i did like a little
um better field work and
all right one other one
okay here's a conspiracy but i feel like
there's so much evidence like it's not
really a conspiracy it's just a fact
um
so in new jersey
it has like the lowest freight crime
rate um
crimes
until that was straight um
then we got eric from mass
hey david i got a question for you it's
eric from mass obviously uh
your boss walks up to you and says uh
hey david uh
uh
i'm gonna fire you if you don't let me
[ __ ] you up the ass okay we're gonna
move on from that back to whitney
so how important is the trust between
um
israel and america
very important very important then back
to this other guy hey david it's jay
dylan um just wondering has anybody
actually read the declaration of
independence and nope nobody's ever read
it same guy called back
hey david it's jay again i'm just uh
i'd like to talk about how the religious
folks seem to be the ones that just
ignore all the [ __ ] signs like you
know the apocalypse that's not happening
around us yep then i think we got to
troy york i just want to say that
congressman jim jordan is a great
patriot
you know what you know what i'm thinking
about
i'm sleeping you know it's 3 a.m i'm
just asleep
the voicemail line it's like ding troy
york calls in ding it's whitney
ding it's eric from mass ding it's the
other guy it's just the all night i'm
asleep and all night all of this stuff
is happening it's really quite a scene
he asked the tough questions that needed
to be asked as usual
he's a honorable proud press all right
so he likes jim jordan then back to eric
from mass oh no hold on here it is
hey david sarah from mass
dude just man the man and as a guy who
watches you and
everything you've got to pivot dude
all the info is coming out and this
contradicts everything you've said the
natural immunity is real study the
vaccine the killing people
um all right and so we're off of that
then it's whitney again
so i have a story of my own
so um
i'm not like one of your leaders
can't even hear it
i have a question um so
how much uh information is like dictated
to you versus like how much information
do you interpret in your own ways it's
all dictated i only take dictation
actually
so what i was thinking about like for
the conservative republican party so
that it doesn't get left behind is like
kind of um paying close attention right
no i agree with that then i think i
think then troy york again
first of all i don't care whether the
date is from 2020 the fact is
crime is rampant and out of control see
that's funny so they've been the
republicans have been going around
showing a
crime chart and it's spikes and they're
like look joe biden and then you look at
it and it's like wait a second sirs and
mams
it spiked in 2020 trump was president
then and then they go well it doesn't
matter the point is crime is up and it's
because of democrats so then it really
doesn't matter that joe biden's
president right well no
that does matter even though the crime
spiked under trump
because under trump it was the fault of
other people you know you guys get it
okay
doesn't make any sense
um let's do a couple more of these i do
want to say thank you to
darren hayne who just signed up on my
website with the coupon code felony21
this is such a beautiful thing
you go on the website and you hit the
sign up button and you type in almost
any coupon code will work quite frankly
but felony 21
look at what it does for us
i'm not even going to say it out loud
because it can't possibly be allowed but
that is something felony 21 is the code
and i encourage you to take advantage of
that one
um thanks to darren hayne for doing that
also want to say thank you to luke on
860 as well as fastn666
pink and blonde and guitar goddess for
their twitch subscriptions putting us at
23 today
a few super chats coming in alex says
whitney is a tdps icon
david do you believe joe manchin and
christian cinema are working in good
faith on the reconciliation bill and do
you think it will be 2.1 trillion two
segments not one but two segments about
that on today's podcast
mike says was never a fan of bill maher
but still trying to figure out when he
turned into dennis miller honestly i
don't know what's up with bill maher now
i haven't seen bill maher
for uh i haven't seen one of his shows
for a really long time so i just don't i
just don't know what he's up to
um couple more from eric from mass
hey david it's eric from mass um
i got a question for you um
do you ever stop and think like when
you're talking
um
and think like wow
it should
hit you you know what i mean you're on
there saying all these healthcare
workers are
gonna uh
quit or
get fired or whatever and you're on
there [ __ ] all over them
and then saying they're lying but here's
the thing
the fact that they're resistant at all a
little bell should go off in your mind
okay
um
here's another one
you know you're getting more fascists by
the day more medical fascists more
retirees no i'm an
anti-authoritarian anti-authoritarian
more medical eternity
you can't fire people from not having
backstreets you can't be telling people
what they can you can no businesses can
businesses can do that
that's not fascism that's that's
letting businesses
as long as it's not against the law
determine who they want working for them
hey mr pacman i just want to say that
it's apparent
um that joe biden is like the most hated
politician of all time yes there is
absolutely no substantive evidence uh on
that
i still can't get over the fact that
um i feel like hillary would have won
part of trump not lied and said that she
was the election
when
there's like um
a parent who thinks that the other
parent molested the child okay we're
going to move on from that
and i noticed this
that a lot of people like started doing
this thing where they're like putting
their heads down and like shaking their
heads to like fake intelligence
and i noticed that like women started
doing it now that's a good observation
very often people will pretend to
understand by going like this when
you're talking to them
that's true a lot of people do fake that
whitney's making a fair point there i
can't i have to tell you all right then
back to this other guy
hey david how you doing it's jay just
wanted to thank you for your coverage of
the trump life festival the other day
that was wonderful confession by the
orange bastard
um
i know if you've watched jesse i've been
uh kind of
throwing bread crumbs out there because
there's enough breadcrumbs to uh make a
pretty big loaf but the loaf tastes like
[ __ ] and oh okay very very aggressive
back to eric from mass
yeah david sarah from mass
man i'm i don't understand i've been
trying to help you
i don't know
i mean
okay the new york times just put out an
article about uh january 6 being an
inside job okay
i think we're maybe done with voicemails
for today
uh let's get away from voicemails for
now i want to say thanks to lindsay
godin who just signed up on my website
joinpackman.com
also a big thank you to hillary lee who
just signed up at joinedpakman.com using
the code felony21
an absolutely perfect day for it also
thanks to chef tragon
who has supported via twitch
twitch twitch prime and related elements
of twitch
few other super chats coming in have you
seen facebook and instagram are down a
day after the whistleblower goes public
are they really i didn't see that let's
see
facebook my facebook's working fine
uh
although all the posts are a day old
that's interesting
so maybe it's like partially back up
facebook and instagram are down let's
see what's happening on instagram
oh i guess it won't refresh as of four
hours ago interesting i did not know
that
yeah so elements are down that's
absolutely true
justin says nothing political to say
love your show david thanks justin very
much appreciate that
and uh great to be great to be back to
streaming um do you guys want to look at
a little bit of an interview between joe
rogan and dr rhonda patrick i saw this
clip she did a really great job of
casually bringing up that there's a lot
of vaccine disinformation being spread
and she sort of seemed to be calling out
joe it was it was actually pretty well
done
um
let's get right into it let's make sure
we've got 1080p for everybody
uh let's listen this is interesting
everywhere
facebook on you know different news
media outlets and and i think there's
really like some some main ones
that that i just feel are
causing harm
and so um
there's really eight of them we don't
need to talk about all of them but i
think the eight really are that you know
sars cove two and it's not that bad copa
19 is not that bad
and
you know vaccines basically
don't prevent transmission
spike protein from vaccines are
cytotoxic therefore they're really bad
now that's a specific one that brett
weinstein has been spreading
she's really i mean she doesn't say it
but she's going after all sorts of stuff
that's been perpetuated
on this very program
that vaccines are going to cause
something called antibody dependent
enhancement which is going to make you
have a more severe disease i think
that's also a weinstein thing
there's the vaccines are going to cause
infertility
there's the um
vaccines are going to cause a more
violent virulent
um strain or variant
and then there's one more
that um
alternatives to vaccines exist right now
that are just as good and i think that
there's a few of those that are really i
mean just like blatantly
they're wrong
all of them i think there but i mean you
know there's some that are more
important than others and i think that
i would like to talk about them um you
know i think first and foremost the
there's like two groups of people
mostly one take thinks copenhagen's bad
doesn't want it guess wants the vaccine
and the other one that thinks it's not
that bad and
uh that the vaccines may be harmful and
there's do you think that vaccines are
harmful to anyone
well of course that's that's sort of
like a weird question
a lot of these questions
are deliberately trying to get away from
the plot anyway but dr patrick hansel
handles it well
i mean do you know anyone that's had bad
reactions to vaccines and again that's
like
if i did what would that change about
the big picture right personally
interestingly the only i know a lot of
people that have gotten vaccinated and
the only person that i know that had
something was like
she had a headache for like a week and a
half and then it went away
um
oh no another person i knew had like
nausea for like a couple of weeks they
were like nauseous more more frequently
but it went away
um you know
do you think you would feel differently
if you knew someone that had a stroke so
so the question there is actually
if you were aware of an anecdote
personally
that was statistically irrelevant would
you have a completely different view as
to the empirical findings that's the
question you know or someone who's had
heart attacks
perhaps young people that have well
it's hard to say so you know i do
people
react differently obviously when you're
giving you know
100 and
more than 169 million people are
vaccinated right i mean that's
half our adult population
is is vaccinated fully vaccinated with
copenhagen
and um it's not zero risk people are
some people are going to have an adverse
reaction and they do it's a big world
out there you know like if you were to
give 169 million people a peanut or a
shellfish like some people are going to
have very adverse reactions something
very very important point there
die like it's it's a big world but you
know with the with the stroke or the
heart attack
you know you have to like
like so if you're trying to compare for
example
let's say you know you're looking at
actual coven 19 deaths and from heart
attacks and strokes and you're looking
at the vaccine adverse events reporting
site there's right and and that as well
you know you have to realize that
basically in the united states like in
2017 there was a publication in the
journal of circulation someone dies from
cardiovascular disease every 30 seconds
in the united states like every 30
seconds most of those people are above
the age of 50 and certainly most are
above 65. but every 30 seconds someone's
dying from cardiovascular disease every
40 seconds someone in the united states
has a stroke
every four minutes they die from a
stroke but this is also very very rare
in young people particularly young
healthy people
but one thing that has occurred in young
healthy people they've been vaccinated
as myocarditis
so this is that's that's important oh my
god where do we go that's important i
think it's there was also a study last
week which said whoops the first data on
the frequency of the myocarditis was
also dramatically overblown that's
important
important now to have that updated data
blood clots like quite a few blood clots
and my understanding is the blood clots
was almost exclusively
women of pre-menopausal age
there's speculation right the salk
institute released that paper about the
uh spike protein
causing uh some sort of deterioration of
the blood vessels did you read that i
looked at the spike i've been looking at
a lot of the um spike protein and that's
from covet 19 they're discussing it
they're talking about from yeah from the
actual disease itself yes so um you know
first of all like they're
one of the issues with this segment and
it's already happening
is that they were dancing around and sam
harris actually has a really really
really good maybe i can find it
um
you don't have to like
like everything sam harris says let me
see if i can write sam harris
it was on a sam harris q a
uh oh this is the one in this one sam
harris actually explains the problem now
i'm jumping around fast to believe the
unbelievable but let's see if we can
let's see if i can find where he talks
about this without remains the purpose
of this podcast
hey corey thanks for the question
yeah this is um
this is a hard one for me actually you
know i i
get the question is why isn't sam harris
debating people like weinstein etc it
seems
crazy not to just flip on the microphone
and talk to the guy
or talk to him and heather this is
really good his
partner in crime
it's hard to put this in a way that
doesn't sound
like a personal attack
but
the reason
why i don't want to do a podcast
with brett and heather
is the same
as why i wouldn't do a podcast with a
911 truth conspiracy theorist or
alex jones or
anyone in that world
because there's a basic asymmetry
which is very hard to overcome
it's so much just happened in the rogan
interview what he describes here just
happened listen to this much easier to
make a mess than to clean it up
it's so much easier to light several
small fires than to put them out
it's like a ten to one advantage
to put it that way it sounds like my
concern is not losing a debate and
that's absolutely not my concern
if you're going to view this as a debate
it's won
almost immediately
but i worry about
what people take
from the encounter and i just don't want
to do
additional harm to our public
conversation about
what is in fact an important public
health concern
and a
growing political one
first the asymmetry the reason why
there's such an asymmetry here is that
it is just impossible
to
debunk
most things in real time right and even
if
the point being made is in fact spurious
it won't seem spurious to 99 of an
audience so let's go back and look at
what just happened here okay
look at what just happened here the
spike protein causing uh some
and some people have had blood clots
like quite a few blood clots and
there's speculation right the salk
institute released that paper about the
spike protein
causing some sort of deterioration of
the blood vessels did you read that
the salk institute released a paper
about the spike protein causing some
kind of deterioration of the blood
vessels did you read that
i don't know i no i i didn't oh my god
how is dr patrick on here talking about
this she doesn't even know about the
sock institute paper which said
something about the spike protein may be
causing the deterioration of blood
vessels which which means what what
what's the greater context
that's exactly
what sam harris is talking about here
well she wasn't prepared on that she
to know through no whole fault of her
own she didn't look at that paper maybe
right and it's exactly what he's
describing here
right so the person on the conspiracy
theory side of things can say
well what about the 14 cdc officials who
resigned what did you you guys were
listening right last week
and wouldn't give reasons when asked
what do you make of that
right now
there's probably nothing to be made of
that right i didn't even hear about it
and the truth is i just made that up
but
when delivered in the context of a quote
debate about these things
with someone who whose whole angle is
there's conspiracy everywhere
it can seem like oh you didn't know
about that well that's clearly a problem
you should look into that
what about the paper that just came out
of micronesia that showed ivermectin was
100 effective
i didn't see that paper out of
micronesia you oh my god how could you
be here talking about it
without seeing the micronesia paper oh
you didn't well okay you should really
do your homework
it's possible to just scatter a lot of
dust in the eyes and ears of the
audience
and make it seem
and by the way how many people will just
repeat the micronesia paper after
hearing it mentioned without ever even
looking as to whether it exists or what
it says like
there's so many anomalies out there
there's so many things that
need to be explained and if you're not
going to explain those things if you're
not going to connect this particular
pattern of dots
well then you're just not doing the work
right
and and that need not necessarily be
done in bad faith of course it can be
right it gets a tactic
but
that's not what i'm alleging
brett and heather would do
i'm just saying that's the way they
think
now it's such a scatter shot approach to
this there's and so that scattershot
nature
is exactly what we're what we're seeing
here
let's listen to a little more of it i
looked at the spike i've been looking at
a lot of the um spike protein and that's
from covet 19 they're discussing it
they're talking about from yeah from the
actual disease itself yes so um you know
first of all like they're
you have to now if i even understand
what's being said the paper
that rogan is referencing if understood
correctly
is saying that that's that's a result of
getting covet not of the vaccine like i
and again it's hard to even follow it
all because of its scatter shot nature
you're you're either going to get
infected with stars growth ii
most people are going to be eventually
we're all going to be exposed to it so
you're either going to be vaccinated
when you're exposed to it or not and
people are dying from heart attacks and
blood clots and even people are getting
myocarditis like 100 full times more
than vaccines like
the the myocarditis link from the mrna
specifically the mrna vaccines is real
and i think the last i saw it was like
50 per million which is still rare and
it's it's happening two people that i
know
it
so
up until then and actually and again
that doesn't really matter what is the
rate
what is the what if two of the 50 out of
a million rogan knows or not i i just
don't understand why that matters so now
that you asked me um i forgot i had a um
someone who's a a supporter um i talked
about vaccines in one of my q as i do
and they went and got it and they were
younger and ended up having some kind of
myocarditis so i do know someone that
had i don't know them but they emailed
me he's heard of something what happens
if you have that and like
how do you recover from that but you
realize it's happening to young people
so myocarditis is caused by two things
one by
inflammation
two by direct viral infection and it's
more common in adolescents and young
people and it's an enlargement of the
heart it's inflammation of the heart can
lead to that yeah but it's it's
happening in young athletes with covet
19 like and it's happening
like more frequently than people that
are getting vaccinated so right an
important point
the myocarditis risk from covid19 to the
same cohort of young people is greater
than the risk of myocarditis from the
vaccine
important point still like well if the
person that got vaccinated look it is a
risk but it's still pretty rare and it
also is
treatable in most cases they treat it
like within a few days and it's isolated
why do you think that people like there
are people that are completely
asymptomatic when they get coveted or if
they do get it's very mild you you see
how we're on a completely different
topic now and that's she i i listen to
other parts of this episode and dr
rhonda patrick's talking about
supplements and different things that i
don't i don't really know much about
whether it's trustworthy or not
but in this particular
portion of this interview she's sort of
trying to stay on the eight types of
coveted disinformation and it's very
difficult to do do you think that's
because they have a lower viral load
that they've been uh infected with i
don't know do you think it's their
immune system that fights it off like
what do you think is happening it could
be any and all of those things a
combination of them and you know
but so like even if you think you know
if you're looking at just like the most
extreme part of like the deaths right
you know you've got like over 624 000
deaths in copen 19 most of those deaths
are happening in people over the age of
50.
um
and if you look at like most of them
have four plus comorbidity factors right
isn't that the average i don't know if
it's okay so now they just talk about
the number of comorbidities which is
another thing all right so you guys get
the point so the point there is she did
go on and make a good faith effort to
sort of point out some of the important
disinformation that's being spread and
it kind of gets
all mixed around like a blender and then
you're trying to figure out what's
what's what it's all kind of mushed
together like a paste a horse paste some
might say
um yeah so it's kind of just
disappointing but
i think that what sam harris
outlined is very accurate we'll listen
to like a little bit more of it so
little
quality control
around the kind of information they're
putting forward
and it takes such an effort to chase it
all down and debunk it and anything that
shows up that's new
in the conversation can't be tracked
down
in real time
so i don't have much hope that a
conversation would wind up producing a
document that would be good for the
world the truth is i'm not the best
person to have the conversation either
it would be good to have an immunologist
or a virologist or yeah all right so you
guys get the picture and and i think
that what's sam harris is making some
really good points there
and in fact a lot of what sam harris
kind of mirrors one of the views
some of the views espoused by neil
postman in his book on technopoly called
technopoly funny enough the book is
called the same thing that the subject
is
from 1992
and it relates to this dynamic that
takes place where
when technologies let me see if i can i
want to try to get this right when a
technology becomes in a technopoly where
we just sort of say like yeah yeah any
new just give us the new technology and
then we'll figure out how to use it and
if it's good or bad or whatever
um
when you just when the technology
becomes invisible like right now
the technology of high-speed internet
and social media
is invisible in the conversation we're
having
we're talking about
a specific show the joe rogan show
and sam harris's view on these so-called
debates about covet disinformation
invisible to that is that it's all
enabled by high-speed internet modern
computing and social media
and a lot of this is simply a result of
the availability of information the idea
that more information is always better
and of course in some vague sense
having access to more information is
better on balance
but additional information
information also has diminishing
marginal returns and the sort of
prototypical example is
if you're going to buy a car
uh before
you had to go to the dealer
and just get your information from the
dealer who had like a little booklet
from the manufacturer okay
um
[Music]
now
you have additional information thanks
to the internet you can now find out
reviews about the car you can go to
edmonds and figure out what are people
actually reporting that they're paying
for the car
it's it's information that gives you
more
substantive
basis for deciding on the car and that's
good
but at a certain point the value of that
additional information start starts to
diminish
once you get down to well what spark
plugs does this car versus that i drive
electric so i don't know if i'm using
the right terms what about the
carburetor i think that's how they say
it the carburetor of this car versus
that car what are the reviews of that
and who makes it and
at a certain point
this is like it doesn't actually really
give us much it it starts to diminish in
value and even arguably become negative
if it paralyzes you and makes you unable
to know anything about a car
that's kind of the analogy to what's
been happening with a lot of this covet
and vaccine disinformation
um and a lot of other stuff that's going
on availability
and people falsely believing that they
are as good as anyone else at
understanding and evaluating information
anyway
i think we get it
um
let's see here we've got a couple people
to ban
and then we're gonna move on
um
are there any coupon codes yes uh you
can use the coupon code
felony21
to get a massive discount on my website
i would love for you to sign up today if
you're just joining us we have announced
a
heretofore unmentioned
live viewer town hall mark it down on
your calendar or however you keep time
however you know what year it is mark it
down there
um
october 19 tuesday october 19 6 pm
eastern we're doing a live viewer town
hall it is going to stream exclusively
on our second youtube channel the pacman
live youtube channel okay
youtube.com pacman live that's where it
will stream it will be open to everyone
to ask questions anybody who wants to
ask questions will be able to ask
questions priority given to website
members so a great day to sign up at
joinpakman.com
coupon code is um felony21
also want to say thank you to
re fee key who has signed up via twitch
prime and his supporter number 27 27
today
uh very much appreciate that okay let's
look at a few other super chats as they
come in here
have you considered or discussed trump's
last moments will be as disgraced as
hitler's last moments 45 is always
compared to hitler's rise but there may
not be enough comparison to both their
falls
uh i have not devoted enough thought to
that to be able to say anything uh
substantive
but i will consider it
jane womanpower says any info showing
rogan's viewers declining what an ass
yeah there is an article that suggests
rogan's audience has declined by half
since moving to spotify
uh i don't know if it's accurate
ryan says you mentioned before you're
okay with crypto sponsors giving you
declare not financial advice
given there are scams i don't think that
does enough to mitigate harm
um
okay yeah i just i just disagree
not
not even a super interesting topic
what is the whistleblower story about
instagram i would adopt you for my son
but i'm up against your mom you're
amazing love from canada i haven't seen
the instagram whistleblower story yet
i don't i'm actually not sure
james says ron desantis's wife casey has
developed breast cancer oh no sources
say ron rushed to help her by signing a
few more executive orders about critical
race theory okay fair fair i understand
the joke but we wish her the best
brandon from st louis says the people in
your voicemail seem to really have their
finger on the pulse
top tier political discourse
um
all right very nice
have i see yes and i saw that that went
down
are instagram and facebook still down
see here
yeah instagram's still down wow
fascinating
uh okay
very good
let's move on yeah i did i i did have a
couple other voicemails i wanted to get
to maybe we will go to it as we wait for
jen saki here she was scheduled to start
a half hour ago expecting her any moment
here
um
uh oh well i've got a bunch of
voicemails here from the same number
here's a new caller
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
[Laughter]
so that's me earlier that's weird
very weird huh
[Music]
[Laughter]
it doesn't matter that your vice
president right well no
that does matter even though man
i'm not even going to say it out loud
because it can't possibly be allowed but
that is something how do you even create
that sound does anybody know and do you
think it will be 2.1 trillion two
segments not one but two segments about
that on today's podcast
mike says was never a fan of
okay
some kind of strange feedback
want yeah for them
i just want to say that it's apparent
um that joe biden was the most hated
politician of all time
it's all
bizarre hi david say i got a good
question for you why don't we ever hear
about the translators that were in at
these putin and trump meetings
you know they got to know everything
that went on i'm just curious why we
never hear about them anyway hey love
your show bro i'll see you yeah they
they do i don't believe they're allowed
to speak about it but you're absolutely
right the issue of the translators has
actually been mentioned before
um but we i mean it seems like they
abide by
uh
the security
of requirements
looking at your video about blacks for
trump i'm a black person not ultra poor
trump uh the black people that in the
video are hired actors most of these
guys have appeared at most of all of
trump's rallies they're in the same spot
as you look most of them are always
at the back or the right to the screen
but these are the same people over and
over again they are an embarrassment to
themselves have a good day okay yeah i
mean
they if they're real they don't think
that they think they're just supporting
the guy that they like or whatever the
case may be hi david so one of the clear
blunders in messaging on the progressive
side
of us politics
has been this
you know 3.5 trillion dollar
package uh
you know messaging and it's not 3.5
trillion dollars today and then another
3.5 trillion dollars tomorrow
it's 3.5 trillion dollars over 10 years
yeah this is a really good point
when people want to make a package look
big
if people want to make their package
look bigger than it is okay
um they'll include the cost over 10
years so like this is a 300 this 3.5
trillion dollar package is really 350
billion over 10 years that doesn't sound
as crazy right for a government the size
of the u.s
on the other side if you want to make it
smaller if you want to diminish the
apparent size of the package
then you say oh it's it's 200 billion a
year that's nothing well okay but it
might dictate 2 trillion in spending
over 10 years or whatever the case may
be just another one of these techniques
just another one of these techniques
um
all right let's see what else we got
here
david i
was on odyssey and checked out your
a video on
the caller that called in about natural
immunity versus the vaccine
and i guess you know i don't have a
problem with you personally but i
think you said two things that kind of
rubbed me wrong one
that
you can't see why anybody wouldn't get
vaccinated number one
number two you claimed
that
natural immunity combined with
uh vaccination is the best
those are i didn't say best best is a
value judgment i said studies show that
the antibody response is highest in
those who have both been vaccinated and
got the virus but that still wouldn't
make me want to go out and try to get
the virus um this is a fact i recovered
from covert uh covert over a year ago i
was one of the early ones that had it
one cool ride i can tell you that
however i have spent a year
researching how i'm just not recognized
they don't
i have not included
in any discussion if you look and you
research you'll find that literally when
they talk what joe biden talked about
okay um not okay this is oh man
i mean there's a couple different things
one is again
you recovered if you got vaccinated you
would have much stronger protection than
whatever protection you have left from
your original infection also if you were
if you were infected at the very very
very beginning of this
there would be a real question as to how
what level of immunity you have if at
all because the virus has changed a lot
since then
you know it's
i don't know guys i don't know
so when i learned about like the
transgender surgeries i suddenly like
started to understand like trump's dance
and like
what he was aiming at as far as like a
um
a representative
and i just really feel like he was like
taking advantage of that when it's like
like the majority of the public knew
exactly like what or why
yeah he recovered from covert
hey david it's jay says hello jesse for
me
uh
here's a question what do you do when
you have parents that
refuse to accept reality
i got a nice argument with my mother who
i
can't really even call anymore
because she's a die-hard trumper because
of my stepfather
she basically denied january 6th
happened like
like she said there was no january 6
that day that year
no i know what you're saying it didn't
happen and it was
antic right right it didn't happen and
it was antifa seriously
like i wanted to hang up the phone
i even sent her a video and i said yes
there was a man that
was beating a police officer with a
flagpole with an american flag attached
to it
she denied it
this is what we're dealing with david
people that flat out deny facts
and i think
that is why biden and everyone else is
kind of buying their time right now to
wait till people to wake up a little bit
but in my opinion i think we've reached
maximum wake up where i don't think
people are waking up anymore it's time
to put this [ __ ] in jail
said jessie my copy of the constitution
as a declaration of independence who is
this jesse that this caller constantly
refers to that he's talking to i
genuinely have no idea whatsoever it's
weird
uh okay i'm receiving word
that the press briefing has been delayed
another hour and 50 minutes to 3 30
eastern
so if that's the case i've got to go and
get to work on tomorrow's show so i'm
going to re-queue up a stream for 3 p.m
i'm gonna put 90 minutes into tomorrow's
show
um and then we'll be back because i'm
reading that it's dramatically delayed i
don't know if it's because of twitter
and inst or instagram and facebook being
down and them wanting to be able to say
something about it i genuinely have no
idea um
but let's get re-cued that'll wrap this
stream
we'll get back back set up for 3 p.m
um
and be uh be back with jen saki all
right see everybody very soon